and finally new rule power is like
owning rabbits
the more you have the easier it is to
get a lot more
that's actually not a new rule it's a
rule as old as time and it was my theme
in this space
two years ago when another supreme court
vacancy was in the news
and that theme that power begets power
should be on everyone's mind right now
the idea that when you lose
power you've not only lost that fight
you made it harder to win the next one
that's how power works
when democrats lose elections they lose
the ability to appoint
judges trump has appointed a quarter of
the entire federal bench and unlike his
wives that's for life
in florida the people voted to restore
voting rights to ex-felons but that's
not really going to happen
because trump appointed five of the six
appeals judges
who found a way to undo that and as is
so often the case make it harder for
democrats to vote
which means more republican senators who
appoint
more conservative judges power is a
perpetuating cycle
like when terminators build more robots
of course democrats are screaming now
about republican hypocrisy over trump
filling the ginsburg seat in an election
year
they said one thing when it was obama
now they're saying the complete opposite
how do they sleep at night
i'll tell you how like a baby
because like a baby
like a baby they have no morals
and if you haven't gotten it yet this
kind of completely
bald-faced premeditated hypocrisy should
make it clear
there's no catching them in an
inconsistency
they don't care because it's all but
only about
power the only rule republicans play by
the only rule they play by is the people
who win make the rules
power talks losers walk
nancy pelosi's response to stopping
trump getting a third seat on the court
was
quote we have arrows in our quiver that
i'm not about to discuss
great now the democrats are bringing
arrows to a gunfight
but i don't think we have any arrows in
our quiver
i think our quiver is bare they have the
power
and they're going to use it to make a
court with six conservatives and when
the 2020 election winds up in the lap of
that court
as they're practically already promising
it will guess who wins
we can't stop them from getting the
court seat which means we can't stop
them from picking the election winner
it's like being in an arm wrestling
contest
you can come back from here it's almost
impossible
to come back from here
how different it all could have been
not to relitigate old wounds but all the
hillary equivocators from 2016
the people who said she was racist not
really that different from trump
the ones who voted third party the ones
who stayed home because you know
the lesser of two evils sorry but you
all have to eat it one more time
because oh how i would love me some of
that hillary evil right now
you know the evil where liberals would
currently have a six to three majority
on the court
the evil where people wouldn't be facing
having their health care taken away or
their right to vote or where america
wasn't sliding into autocracy
yes yes let's uh
let's look at the alternative universe
if a few more people in 2016 had told
themselves
yeah she's not my favorite but you only
get two choices in our system it's
probably better to make sure this sane
competent person gets in as opposed to a
malignant narcissist
in that universe we're still in the pr
paris climate accord
and iran's nuclear program is still
frozen and maybe so is greenland
there have been none of the rollbacks on
clean air
and water dreamers don't have to worry
about getting tossed out of the only
country they've ever known
william barr is just a right-wing crank
self-publishing a book on our moral
decline
and brett kavanaugh is drinking from
home
oh oh it's a it's a wonderful world this
world
people hearing the words p-tape only
think of r kelly
[Applause]
and no one has needed or heard of a pink
[ __ ] hat let alone try to knit one
and look no nation as fundamentally
unhealthy as this one could escape a
pandemic unscathed
but i think hillary would have done a
little better than let them drink bleach
so
[Music]
the supreme court hears oral arguments
to overturn
obamacare on november 10th once this new
justice is seated
obamacare is likely gone and after that
roe versus wade so i hope you enjoy
carrying your rape baby to term you can
name it jill stein
yes joe biden is far from a perfect
candidate and i have serious doubts
they'll ever let him take office but
giving him
a vote total so huge it will be hard to
ignore
is the very last hail mary pass we have
you